[Music]
no one else has like every time I do it
it you do it cuz you just pick your
finger dealing with [__]
[Music]
that's how we open up a [__] show
[__] welcome Oh chuckle Joey with
his trusty little Jewish friend Lisa yet
and we ain't [__] around no more you
understand me it's Tuesday the 20th it's
a surprise attack podcast just [__]
around we're going deep tonight you
weren't prepared for this one so it's
time [__] go run run get that we
get the grinder get the bong get the
explosives get the pipe get the fluence
a cup you whack off in get the
flashlight with Lindsay Lohan's [__] in
it we're going deep into the murky
waters or the underworld and your boo
Joey you go deep every night that's
right we're training cops up there once
we get to that [__] Isis camp we'll
be running things once they put us in
the ice skate camp we'll have our own
[__] jail cell but we smoking weed
then I'll have to [__] with us
[__] if you don't think Isis is
watching this periscope don't be [__]
fool [__] when I was in college I
got told it from Muhammad's of babies
Isis now I don't give a [__] he sends me
postcards with dead white people in
training camp he's in training camp
lifting weights doing botnets but who
gives a [__] what he opening up a
[__] Tuesday night you thought you
were just in a sit-down I don't know
what to do it's a ho-hum Tuesday night
BAM then we show up [__] [__]
JonBenet Ramsey who get some [__]
Gilbert that was 20 years ago was the
father a mother and that little
perverted [__] brother you understand
[Music]
just like that people it's a good night
here we got water we got stars and we
got reefer that's it that's all you need
if you want to play Gilligan on a
[__] Island you follow me there's
Uncle Joe ain't [__] around no more
the countdown has become to the special
Rosemont we're [__] invading Jews
Timmy Holloway Irish people
Cubans it's all over tell that Ruth
Chris we're gonna [__] light it on
fire and eat everything in that
[__] but enough is enough
Joey drop some [__] knowledge on us
with the bomb
sometimes that's the most important
thing sometimes you'll even need to say
none just blow smoke on a [__]
and watch you
[Music]
mm you're thinking to yourself what the
[__] is going on over there
and the party don't stop you understand
me look at this Phil [__] bag we got
blood ones we got [__] purple ones we
got red ones - four won't be touching
them will you little Jew fingers we
gotta galaxy Emily baby right away wants
to put that tech that [__] Jerusalem
thing down my stars this [__] I'll be
sitting there all dizzy like Jesus on
the cross looking I'm so [__] horizon
thinking whether I go wrong
did I not cut these Jews in why are they
doing this to me oh [__] that's right
[__] we're gonna eat every
single two hundred milligram in this
[__] tonight so we got four five
three five six six six and a half we're
going for 1,300 off the bat right off
the bat ain't no make someone match and
I told you to eat a good dinner listen
we're like the Japs tonight's a surprise
attack you know I'm saying [__] even Lee
didn't know it was crackin I gonna meet
me at the office [__] second cool
please count them with me please over
there home miss Brett boom burn that's a
thousand down [__]
I can get eighteen Chinamen I can't do
that
don't do you got - well then we're gonna
split this one forget about it I told
you [__] and she used to be
mine
there you go [__] that's how we
do it
13 off the bat and never feel we got
back up here like a [__] I'm
saying kick this zone up to 1,500
tonight I gotta go home and nappy noodle
this [__] well that's it it's a good
Tuesday night usually we going to a
[__] not a happy hour shillelaghs or
something like that we a little half a
[__] French not tonight you with
yong-chol Joey Diaz we'll keep doing
bong hits or somebody [__] passes out
today if you got a bomb join us if not
run down the [__] head shops open
till 10:00 [__] leave well you
make a funny face this for you haven't
even done the bonnet that yet this is
the new weed this from the cancer clinic
right this is they let you smoke before
you shoot yourself this is it right here
[__]
look at that nice nicey-nice you see you
fill up right there to the brim look at
that look at that green [__] weed
right so I can stop causing the dark
with this [__] weed
[Music]
look at that damn huh just when you
thought it was safe you got to keep
those lungs pushing [__]
dang gonna do it by itself you smoke
weed you get bas Rutten ho2 out of brief
forget about it you took a blow [__]
bubbles I've been doing it for two days
now the h2o the [__] bas Rutten tank
is your abdominal muscles teaches how to
push air out what's that getting
training there I'm gonna blow smoke
through the [__] phone the phone's at
the bone that's how I roll [__]
but never feel Lisa I hate it ready for
a bomb that he's sitting there looking
at me give me the Jew I going Joe
deserve this disrespect you over there
smoking with three hands and you give
uncle [__] leading up I should you
give a [__] want to slip and
break his Lincoln say the Jew I used to
do it all the time for the Italians it's
not my look to the Jews it's the Jew I
came the Jew eyes in the slipper formas
no [__] that talk stuff hopefully hits
13 stitches to his eyeball anyway we're
here what we're not we doing I'm happy
you join me I'm happy to send the
messages it's a shame I can't [__]
see nothing so don't matter keep typing
[__]
[Music]
I don't want you coming here and wasting
all my time and talking to your sleeve
[Music]
that's the point
beautiful it's nice and clean now give
me a little fondant I don't want to give
them too much I'm saying we'll have to
stick that needle in you Blood Brothers
someday you don't say listen if I [__]
my [__] thing up yes no you'll be -
that's just the way it works out fever
hey it might get a little clock
let's keep sucking that mother [__]
oh that's beautiful right there people
that's a bond right there that's the one
that's gonna knock his eyeball out right
there this is the bomb that killed
[__] Mussolini it's the way we do
last week I popped my lung and went to
the hospital 30 minutes add it back in
like nothing I don't want you coming red
what the [__] get up and dance I don't
give a [__] what you need to do it's
Tuesday night you know everybody else is
at home hey what did the president say
who gives a [__] what the president said
it's an uncle Joey says [__] smoke
- you [__] pass out today
[Music]
give me a Taco Tuesday
this is bong hit Tuesday I do yo please
elbow sir you know that that means the
THC is working it's seeping through his
[__] veins sometimes is what it's all
about a few pockets of my little goombas
a [__] you know I love you [__]
[Music]
let's see what I got here
let's go gold people's I can see leaves
in the mood
oh yeah we always like to take something
chocolately
and he's like [__] me at night [__]
[__] the cars first down
this kids a lullaby to me to sleep let's
hit this [__] hard now you don't
like to [__] around here when in doubt
we sold our soul for rock and roll you
could keep putting up those Purple
Hearts fairy your Purple Heart you
[__] put up we twin devastated that's
how we do it give us you those
commercials for the [__] haul every
dollar you invest we'll invest it no you
want no you will but if every [__]
star you pop will pop ass dog we had a
fill thankfully we got a full bag and
nothing to do you understand me look at
least wet he's got drool on his shirt
listen
and you know the reef is good when you
got drool on your shirt ready for one
more [__] on you stressed along you
stressed alone now it's ready now you're
[__] ready said cupola to lever kiln
open actual all the time [__] my pants
[Music]
like a soldier looking see that people
this retraining does is how we do people
724 we don't need to [__] do hats and
posters and that you just show up with
the real reason and the one bundle is
about the [__] melt understand me
we've almost melted his [__] bunk
three times and then tomorrow's dreams
become realities to me [__] what
are you looking at your [__] over here
making it happen I wish you
[__] wait what are you gonna do
look at me he's done he looks like one
of Escobar's soldiers look at them
you look say one to Escobar sicarios
look at them less Lamar look at them
that's it little manly bone you know
it's that type of night people so I
don't know a planchette I don't know
what that plan is you [__] Sam
you know we don't talk every day we
don't get chat you don't send me no [__]
the messages but I will tell you we had
a [__] plan we called and said let's
go down and bong get the debt on
periscope we'll do a [__] podcast
before you leave the whole [__] deal
so please the Captain Kirk aka ramón
limón are you [__] nuts or what that
driver from Escobar that is stumbled it
to the end you got shot [__] that
happens we sent the family some flowers
everybody's happy
what are you gonna do I think we should
do one more bonding I'll start the
podcast what do you [__] this
thing listen you know one more that
won't bother you no more for the rest of
the [__] week I'll be doing
paratroops
I'll be doing periscopes direct from the
streets in New York at one point
hopefully there'll be an explosive
behind me the whole [__] block blows
and you got it on periscope who's better
here you could [__] eBay it to the
Germans whatever the [__] you want to do
it your time yeah I'm saying I'm just
saying oh [__] we'll smoke a little bum
get out of respect
the fairies web Bootsy understand me we
don't want another Lisa and I'm good to
go my heart won't stop beating out of my
[__] shirt like when I was 13 I got
my first heart the heart don't you
Azul guys what the [__] you got me to
tell you I'm no [__] physicist I'm no
[__] engineer I'm just a fat felon
comic that's trying to have a good time
and this [__] silver lining is I'm no
man young thing just trying to have my
water I'm not putting on no facade so
I'm not hanging out with [__] what's
his name what's his name
champagne cocktails which is me [__]
Shack you know come on I don't know but
I have with my little [__] trusted
associate Lisa yeah one of the baddest
men has wheels Israel's ever sent over
you call it the pong nobody know about
Lisa I'll tell you what the [__] do you
know about Lisa where is he Switzerland
Europe South Africa can't keep track on
Lisa
little do they know he's right here in
LA with his uncle joy what he's belong
in other words
[Music]
it's time to freak Lea
who gives a [__]
Savin two in the afternoon that's the
problem at the country everything's are
the time to see the devil listen it's
always a good time to see the devil a
well I look through a window and
surprise what I saw
[Music]
remember wanna swap [__] walrus walk
there's uncle Joey with them yet
families wear boots sang you gotta
believe man oh [__] finally ladies and
gentlemen give me ten minutes
youtube.com / c / Joey D is gonna do a
little [__] I wanna have podcast nice
and quick no drama we got some topics to
talk about and that's it that's that who
the [__] are you kiddin you showed up
you halfway
what the [__] what do you owe your time
now you go back and watch Netflix the
[__] black who gives a [__] uncle
Joey got you look at my trusted [__]
boom buddies look at them [__] look
at them look at those eyeballs show them
the eyeball free sign that you
understand me that's the Jew art that
means you better tune in [__]
stay black